most of my friends are atheists I would
say and so being a self-identified
Christian is so loaded in my field of
stand-up comedy which has such a
contrarian spirit look the Catholic
Church has done horrible things horrible
things you know the sexism bigotry you
know just monstrous things but so is the
United States of America
I mean genocide and slaving people but
I'm still American and I feel a sense of
pride in that identity I'm not
apologetic like when I travel
internationally and people are negative
towards Americans I get angry I get
annoyed so for me it's not about the
participants in this belief system that
I share it's the what the belief system
provides me the concept of Mercy is very
appealing to me the concept that there
is something greater than me that it's
forgiving is very important to me but
being a comedian it's such a strange
path being a comedian because I'm also a
clean comedian I'm considered a clean
comedian which is a very backhanded
compliment comedians don't want any
adjectives they don't want to be a
female comedian they don't want to be a
black comedian they don't want to be a
gay comedian they want to be a comedian
the only adjective that a comedian wants
is funny you know like if you're
attractive you don't want to be like a
funny good-looking commedia they just
want funny
so being a clean comedian is it's weird
because it's almost kind of like an
asterisk it's like yeah you know the
funny clean comedian comedy is such a
rich kind of irreverent fighting
censorship mentality so being clean you
know Mark Twain was clean you know you
know George Carlin was clean before he
did seven dirty were seven words you
can't say right so clean is not a great
adjective but that being said from a
historical standpoint most comedians
were clean there were one or two that
there was Lenny Bruce but the rest of a
majority of them or you know not a
majority but I would say a great portion
of them were clean so I did an interview
a year ago with Larry King who's now a
hundred and nine years old and he told
me the interesting thing is is he used
to ask comedians
why are you dirty that was the question
he would ask them and now he asks why
are you clean I like to think that
George Carlin and Lenny Bruce and
Richard Pryor broke all these you know
barriers so that I could talk about
mini-muffins
comedians do the type of comedy they're
going to do whether its irreverent
obnoxious yelling or quiet they do the
type of comedy they're gonna do and then
people give credit or criticism to it so
in other words people go that person is
so brave are they brave rue is that's
the type of comedy that we're gonna do
anyway you know so people will say it's
thank you for being clean I'm like
that's just how it comes out
I'm not sitting there you know people
who sometimes will say why are you a
clean comedian and I said cuz Jesus told
me it makes no sense it's what works for
me so what works for Chris Rock and
Louis black and Dave
pal is what they do now you know clean
and irreverent and filthy are these
strange kind of adjectives that's not to
say that individually comedians aren't
challenging themselves but challenging
yourself is not I'm not gonna curse or I
am gonna curse you challenge yourself in
being more honest and being more
authentic or talking about an issue in a
in a creative way so that's why you'll
see some people just preaching these
social issues as a comedian and in my
opinion yeah those are important social
issues but it's not funny but if you can
craft it in a funny way in a more subtle
way where you're reflecting on how all
human beings and maybe addressing
homophobia it's much more potent so but
again like I said I think comedians just
do what they're gonna do I'm from a
small town in Indiana I curse every day
but I'm not the type person that's gonna
stand in front of 1,800 people and
discuss the love life that I have with
my wife or bury my wife onstage
it's just not my mentality so anyway
that's my rant on that